Олексій Гончаренко європейська
Солідарність шановні друзі народовладдя
- це краєугольний камінь нам це
абсолютно потрібно підтримувати завжди
Тому будь-якої ініціативи в цьому
напрямку ми підтримували І будемо
підтримувати і за цей закон ми будемо
голосувати але дуже важливо щоби ми
створювали реальні інструменти які
будуть працювати а не просто номінальні
речі бо Подивіться наприклад на інститут
петиції який я дуже добре які є дуже
правильний люди підписуються на сайті
президента але Що відбувається далі от я
став ініціатором петиції де ім'я
Президента щодо розгляду законопроекту
про обмеження впливу е-е російської
Православної церкви на Україну цей
законопроект Він є 8347 в Верховній Раді
України в рекордні терміни 25 000
підписів пішло президенту І що І нічого
ми до цих пір його не розглядаємо щось
десь якісь інші законопроект готують а
п'ята колона ФСБ на дрг під виглядом
церкви продовжує працювати ми
зареєстрували я зареєстрував петицію на
сайті Президента щодо підтримки
постанови про те щоби прибрати руський
мір з українського парламенту о ПСЖ геть
з українського парламенту не мають бути
тут і це є вимога українського
суспільства в рекордні терміни за 12
годин ця петиція набрала 25,000 голосів
І що І нічого Це пішло на президента
президент відправив Верховну Раду
Верховна Рада все вагається щось
розглядає і результати до цих пір нема
тому друзі демократія - це не тільки
слова це не тільки інструменти але і
їхня реалізація давайте нарешті зробимо
очистимо український парламент від
п'ятої колони приберемо вплив церкви яка
не є церквою А є ячейкою ФСБ Оце і буде
справжня демократія